pues buenas tardes raúl de momento no
hay ninguna confirmación oficial como lo
acaban de escuchar pero lo que sí que
está claro como lo confirmó messi en
esta rueda de prensa es que están
hablando actualmente con el club
parisino pero también añadió que en
cuanto se hizo oficial su marcha del
club barcelona pues había recibido otras
ofertas de otros clubes lo que está
seguro es que messi sigue con ganas de
jugar y aquí pues centenares de
aficionados se congregaron con el
convencimiento de que messi se llega al
psg porque el segundo ese es el único
club que se puede permitir
económicamente al crack argentino de
hecho algunos franceses turistas estaban
también aquí frente a este con ellos
para celebrar la marcha de messi del
club blaugrana pero messi también dejó
claro una cosa que volverá a barcelona
primero porque se lo cometió a sus hijos
y segundo dijo porque aquí es su casa
ellis cómo queda entonces el legado de
messi
y cómo queda la liga española
pues el legado de mesía aquí son cifras
impresionantes 21 años de carga 35
títulos de hecho estos treinta y cinco
trofeos estaban expuestos en el
auditorio donde se celebrada esta rueda
de prensa del camp nou y es una
exhibición que impresiona obviamente
pero también impresiona su legado para
la liga española de fútbol 383 son las
victorias en la competición doméstica
con lo que es actualmente el mes y pues
el jugador con más triunfos en esta liga
y así podríamos seguir con más cifras
que prueban los récords del crack
argentino obviamente significa que hoy
la liga pues pierde a un gran jugador y
esto le afectará económicamente como
también afectará al club y hoy afectaba
a los aficionados que muchos estaban
aquí él jogando frente al camp nou
esperando a que saliera el argentino
para despedirse por última vez del crack
en el camp nou